you had quite the summer of love i
believe a love story in the world of joe
lyson
i'm gonna go with the answer no
oh i um romance
i tried at romance i went on a date well
is this that i think it was the second
date with a girl and um she was saying
that she wanted to go on holiday okay to
greece
so i was looking for a vagina
she wanted some vagina
so i um was looking on google maps for
greece because i don't know greece that
was looking at she said she wanted to go
to an island and i landed on kefalonia i
said why can i remember kefalonia and
then this is a little name drop i
remembered i'm i'm close personal
friends with
uh
children's entertainer paul chuckle
off of the chuckle brothers yes and he'd
said to me once oh i've got a villa on
kefalonia joe that's how he talked paul
paul chuckle is um a famous remnant it
will take too long it will take too long
i think that says it all yeah yeah
yeah
they sort of they're a removal men
basically and um
paul chuckles he's so nice and he's so
lovely he's so generous and he's got
this villa on kefalon and he said you
can stay there if you whenever you like
joe so i said to her i said
i i've got this friend called paul
trucker and she's like i know paul
dracula's um he's got a villa
could stay there if we wanted to and i'd
text him and he said it was free and she
said 100 so basically i ended up in
portugal's villa with a girl i'd met two
times
and
it became very clear
that it was we were very much in the
friend zone
and um i was quite disappointed because
basically i just i mean the villa is
exactly how you'd imagine it it's
it's fine and um
no offense paula we had a lovely time
but um you know i was there for a few
days and realized that oh we're in the
friend zone and basically i just you
know you wanna when you're having sex in
paul chucklesville you wanna go to me to
you that's all i want
[Applause]
[Music]
you